you might have heard about BF Skinner
you know he used food pellets to
motivate his rats but what you don't
know about Skinner is that those rats
were starved to 3/4 of their normal body
weight so they would who would work for
food and so Skinner's routes were kind
of oversimplified but you can get rats
to work for food they don't have to be
that hungry you can get them to work for
food and they'll do all sorts of things
they'll press levers and and they'll
open bar open doors and they'll solve
problems and you know they'll do all
sorts of things and one of the things
you can do to kind of measure how much
the rat is motivated is let's say you've
run him through a maze and he knows
there's some food at the end of the maze
you can tie a little spring to his tail
and see how hard he pulls when you open
the door to the maze so that's because
that's how much rat work the route is
willing to do so you can measure that or
you can see how fast he skitters down
the maze and you can get an estimate
about the rats motivation and so then
you might say well how motivated is a
hungry rat and the answer would be
depends on how hungry is but there's
another answer it also depends on what's
chasing him when he's going after the
food so if you have a rat and you you
have food over here and you waft in some
cat odor rats hate cat odor and it's
innate they never have to see or smell a
cat to be absolutely petrified by cat
odor and so if you walked in some cat
odor and then open the door that rat
will zoom to that food a lot faster than
it will if it's just hungry so a rat
running away from something that it
doesn't want towards something that it
does want is a very motivated rat and so
one of the things we did with the future
authoring program that's germane to this
idea of terror because there's an is
this idea in the old testament the fear
of God is the beginning of wisdom and
it's a pretty harsh idea but but there's
something really useful about it because
one of the things you see with people
all the time is that they're maybe
they're trying to stumble forward
towards their ideal as poorly defined as
it might be but then they're afraid
right they're afraid about what they
might encounter and that stops them
because fear does stop people it freezes
you like a prey animal and so people
move ahead but then they get afraid and
then they start moving ahead and so and
that's not so good because negative
emotion is a really powerful mode of
so we're more motivated by negative
emotion than positive emotion
quantitatively speaking quantitative
quantitatively speaking you can measure
that and that's I think because we can
only be so happy but we can really be
suffering and yet you know so we have to
pay more attention to the negative and
that's bad because the negative can stop
you and then in my clinical practice you
know I often talk to people who are
trying to make a difficult life decision
and and they are weighing out the costs
and the benefits of making the life
decision you know and one of the things
I always talk to them about is wait a
second that's an incomplete analysis you
have to weigh out the benefits and the
costs of doing this and you have to
weigh out the costs and benefits of not
doing that not doing it and that's not
the same as the zero that you assume
that you're starting with right because
to not make a decision also has a cost
and sometimes the cost of not making a
decision is far worse than the cost of
making a decision even if the decision
is risky and so one of the things you
can derive from that and this is very
useful I think is that this is also I
think why it's so useful to contemplate
your mortality so to speak as you're
screwed no matter what you do you know
and that actually frees you is that you
you have power to aid that has cadastre
reason you have path B that has
catastrophes and you don't get to have
the no catastrophe path but you get to
pick which one and that's really
something because if you know that
there's terrible risk associated with
everything that you do and don't do then
you can afford to take some risks
because you're not you know and this is
all within the arc metaphor I'm still
making the case that despite the fact
that your life is essentially
catastrophic you can you can make a
covenant with the highest ideal and that
will take you through it the best way
possible and I'm still making that case
so so then you think okay well I'm
trying to make this decision I'm gonna
go try to do something difficult and
isn't that terrifying and then you think
yeah but wait a minute what's really
terrifying is not doing it and then you
think about the cost of not doing it so
in the future authoring program we have
people do this little meditative
exercise which is okay just think about
your insufficiencies by your own
definition right the way that you don't
do
what you know you should do about the
things that you do that you shouldn't do
that you know you shouldn't do beyond a
shadow of a doubt right there's some
things like that and that that's bad
habits and poor aim and all of the
resentment and hatred and aggression and
unresolved conflicts and all those
things that are demanding you and
warping you and then think okay
those things get the upper hand man they
get the upper hand and they take you the
worst possible place you could go in the
next three to five years what exactly
does that look like and so you sketch
all that out you think hey I don't want
to go there and so the next time that a
temptation comes up you think well I'd
be a lot better for me if I didn't
succumb to this temptation it's like
that's kind of weak a you'd look a
little better if you didn't eat like a
cheesecake a day or something like that
you know that's that's something but
it's not the same as I'm gonna have
diabeetus and I'm gonna lose my damn leg
in in five years if I don't get my
eating under control that's motivating
and so then the temptation comes along
and you think oh how about no seriously
how about no not just because a higher
good would be obtained if I avoided it
but because a terrible catastrophe would
be averted if I didn't and so well so
you want to get your fear behind you
right you want to get it behind you
where it's pushing you forward instead
of in front of you where it's stopping
you and you get your fear behind you
pushing your for you forward by actually
thinking through the consequences of not
putting your life together and the least
of those is that you waste it and suffer
right because you can't suffer anyways
man so you waste it and suffer that's a
bad deal because maybe if you're gonna
suffer you could at least do something
Noble and glorious and upright and
powerful and honorable and admirable and
helpful and and difficult you know
that's just so much better and maybe
that's good enough so that you think hey
you know little suffering
it's basically worth it at least it's up
WayForward you know at least it's a way
forward